bonsoir
bonsoir le prix du pétrole en ce moment
est à 100 105 110 112 dollars mais le
prix de l'essence monte et monte encore
comment comment on explique cette
situation
il faut comprendre que le pétrole brut
il a la tête première la première
matière qui compose les sens mais
évidemment il ya plusieurs
secteurs leur influence se prit donc
qu'un prix du pétrole brut dieu le prix
aussi de l'essence raffinée et à sa faut
ajouter aussi le taux de change a le
plus que autant le pétrole brut que le
prix à la raffinerie là est basé sur le
prix dans le port de new york par contre
le temps beaucoup changé pour beaucoup
changé le taux de change des dernières
semaines dans 67 et 72 cents américains
elle effectivement et mais c'est un des
facteurs mais évidemment pu par la suite
on ne faut ajouter les taxes et la marge
du détaillant c'est sûr que le prix du
pétrole brut a augmenté mais également
la marge de raffinage est assez
important oui on va y venir à la marge
de raffinage au juste montré un
graphique où on voit un écart quand même
grandissant dans les dernières semaines
entre le prix de l'essence et le prix du
pétrole la ligne bleue c'est le prix de
l'essence la ligne rouge c'est le prix
du pétrole généralement c'est à peu près
corrélés mais là il ya un écart qui
s'est agrandie au cours des dernières
semaines qu'est ce qui se passe pour que
le prix de l'essence c'est la marge des
détaillants qui augmente
écoutez la marge des terres aujourd'hui
à montréal est assez tu donc et en
juillet la marge est aujourd'hui lé
talent et est assez de soucis on regarde
ailleurs au québec elle est très mince
peu pour tourner autour d'une femme dans
certains secteurs du québec mais déjà la
douce voix qu 1,5 le litre
oui effectivement ça peut arriver des
fois de façon très sporadique il faut
comprendre que parfois elle est négative
parfois elle est plus importante et
c'est en moyenne qu'on regarde est-ce
que ça permet aux détaillants couvrir
ses coûts d'exploitation
donc c'est tout aujourd'hui c'est une
marge qui est très raisonnable qui
permet
c'est quand même difficile de comprendre
madame marcotte l'écart entre le prix
des détaillants le prix de l'essence à
la pompe et le prix du pétrole en
principe c'est corrélés et là on dirait
que ça ce décor est le
média le marché du raffinage lui qui
vient un peu bouleversé les choses si on
veut parce que la marge de raffinage est
plus importante on comprendre que ben il
faut comprendre que les graphies né au
québec dont eu le prix des raffinements
paix québec est corrélé à celui du
marché du port de new york par exemple
donc évidemment parce que le marché des
raffineries québécois ce n'est pas
seulement que le marché québécois là ils
peuvent est exportée au sida pourquoi
pourquoi les marges de raffinage
augmentent
mais petit à doite se putréfier que tout
ce qui se passe en ukraine présentement
en europe une demande grandissante
ça peut venir influencer le les prix au
port de nous là évidemment il pourrait
avoir de l'exportation de produits
raffinés vers les régions alors vous
nous avez préparé vous avez sorti les
chiffres à notre demande on veut
comparer 2008 avec aujourd'hui le 10
juin 2008 le prix du baril de pétrole si
je me trompe pas et à 145 150 dollars et
aujourd'hui le 16 mai 2022 le prix du
pétrole est autour de 112 113 dollars
donc on voit ce que ça coûte en scène tu
parlais de 91 cents par litre
aujourd'hui par rapport à 84,5 sonne le
10 juin 2008 mais la marge de raffinage
est passé de 9,4 à
48,2 qui ensuite on a la taxe carbone
les taxes qui s'ajoute et donc le prix à
la pompe dans le grand montréal 215 9
par rapport à un dollar 51 le 10 juin
2008 je repose la question comment on
explique la marge de raffinage qui a été
multiplié par cinq
et péter fill tu comprends mis à part
pas sur justement sur les marchés
internationaux qui vient impacter là le
prix à la raffinerie évidemment les
détaillants que je refuse présentent eux
sont tributaires du prix à la raffinerie
n'ont pas le choix que d'acheter lol le
prix aux raffineries québécoises est
d'ailleurs aujourd'hui
avant l'état un détaillant qui peut
payer une dollars 48 et une fois qu'on
achète un ajout qui épate ses coûts de
transport pour détaillants montréal ça
lui coûte de dollars 7 avant même
d'avoir vendu et payer ses coûts
d'exploitation
ok mais je n'arrive pas à comprendre si
l'ukraine essentiellement c'est quoi les
capacités de production également les
capacités de raffinage qui sont encore
minces et en amérique du nord
probablement que les raffineries
seraient plus en mesure de répondre à
cette question mais vous êtes pétrole
vous devez avoir une petite idée madame
marcotte oui mais comme je vous dis
c'est sûr que les bouleversements qui se
vident le sur le marché mondial vient
impacter le prix à l'affiner également
puisque les raffineries québécoises sont
à son influence est le parent par le
prix hopper de nouilles qu'est ce que
vous pensez de la proposition du parti
québécois qui dit qu'il faudrait limiter
le prix de l'essence plafonner le prix
de l'essence 1 $ 60 le litre
comme je vous dis aujourd'hui avec les
taxes un détaillant paye son essence de
dollars alors si on limite et il le prit
à la raffinerie 8 dollars 48 avant même
d'avoir ajouté les taxis on limite le
prix les raffineries québécoises
pourraient choisir d'exporter leurs
produits leurs pattes du raffiné à
l'extérieur donc il faut comprendre
qu'on est dans une économie de marché et
que le marché des raffineries
québécoises et plus grands
questionnements plus qu'aider et
éliminer les taxes par exemple ou abc
des taxes pour aider les gens
temporairement est ce que c'est une
option viable pour vous mais c'est sûr
que ça ferait baisser les prix
évidemment puisque les taxes ont
augmenté avec le temps on ne peut le
voir donc en 2008 par exemple les taxes
était l'équivalent d'à peu près 45 sous
alors qu'aujourd'hui les taxes toutes
taxes confondues autour de 68 et
évidemment qu'ils ont baissé les taxes
ça ferait baisser le prix est ce que ça
lui ferait baisser suffisamment sûre
c'est un choix de société aussi qu'il
faut faire parce que c'est de l'argent
qui repas dans les pop guetta c'est toi
à nous lors de
cette heure là c'est vraiment chouette
société d'accord sonia marcotte merci
beaucoup pour ses explications ce soir
ça m'a fait plaisir pour voir nos
émissions en entier rendez vous sur la
chaîne ici et redit